have you connected with Glo really yet
oh yeah we we've talked we haven't made
any music though I feel like you guys
would make a joint if you want to I'd be
trying to she'd be busy though she yeah
she's just gonna go tour yeah she real
busy what is your diet like right now I
feel like every time I see you you're
you got some sort of expensive water or
some wild [__] you're eating what are
you like is there like a specific diet
you're on right now a raw alkaline diet
that's the same thing you're on last
time so for people who don't know what
is a raw alkaline diet so only fruits
and like vegetables and only things
that's like raw and alcohol so pretty
much
um nothing cooked
and uh no cooked food no cooked food so
it's like salads or just no meat fruits
no Meats still vegan
alkaline vegan diet wow do you miss meat
at all um
how terrible is an impossible Burger
and Plaza Burger tastes real good
actually I gotta try it yeah it just
looks good now is it good for you no
it's not good for it's terrible for you
but it tastes good though uh you're from
Memphis obviously one of the biggest out
the city but John Morant who's been in
the news recently uh has gone through so
I feel like some of the stuff that you
kind of went through early on in your
career would be advice you would give
John a rant man
um I always just knowing that um God
send you a storm for you to learn
something from it you know what I'm
saying for you to overcome it and um for
you to have appreciation for the
blessing he gave you because he could
show you how quick he can take it away
from you as well so um he'll learn it
quick and he'll be right over